[Music]
do you have or could you describe
a
meaningful or favorite failure and by
that i mean
any anything that seemed like a failure
at the time or was a failure
that
was particularly valuable
for you looking back or that set you up
in some fashion for
later success does anything come to mind
did you say favorite failure
did you say that those are the words i
used yes
failing sucks
it's painful i mean it is i don't know
if i'd use the word favorite yeah yeah
meaning most insightful insightful yes
okay yes we can definitely re
label it however you like but yeah
in effect
i say that whimsically partly
i really hate losing time intensely
also something common for quite a few
members of the paypal mafia
yeah which you know has its downsides
obviously so you know
one of the things we talk about in our
partnership is the sins of commission
and the sense of omission
and the sense of commission is we made
an investment we shouldn't have
and the sins of our mission are the ones
you didn't but should have
and
i've probably made six seven investments
in my career already that literally went
to zero
and
i don't think i should really highlight
any of them because you know we made a
good try the founders were great didn't
quite work out and it was valiant we did
what we we could i will tell you that
the first time i had an investment that
went 2-0 it was a 10 million complete
write-off i literally cried in our
partner meeting because i had such
such an immense sense of shame
and guilt for having failed
and for having lost money for unlimited
partners and it was an important moment
partly because my
the senior partners at sequoia i think
part of what we do well as a team part
of our longevity is the way that we help
each other and so senior partners who
had gone through this themselves were
there to support me and to you know
guide me through this because the danger
in the business is if you've had an
experience like that is you recoil
and and you become very careful and
you'll never
get back to the glory days maybe like an
athlete who has a severe injury and they
never want to test that knee again
you know because they had a bad knee
injury or something they'll never attain
what they had in the past so so that to
me was a very painful experience but the
ones that really sting are the ones we
should have made and i think back to
meeting jack when he was at twitter
i met him
an ev and we had an opportunity to
invest in the series a twitter this is
in 2007.
so this is before the iphone was
released there was no twitter app this
was text messaging
different business
and i just didn't dream enough i failed
to imagine what might happen with a
service like this and that was
incredibly painful for me and we missed
the a
and we missed the b and we missed the c
and that was a huge lesson for me and i
you know sometimes you can explain away
an investment you didn't make by saying
well ex ante were those same facts would
you make the same decision today or not
because obviously exposed you should
have made the investment but ex-ante you
know sometimes things just you know
they're weird twists and turns in the on
the road to company building
and so maybe you could justify that the
series a was you know
a bit more random because it took a lot
from there to where they were in say
2010
but by 2010 we should have looked at it
and reevaluated our decision
and that i feel really guilty for that
was terrible
i really really messed up
for not revisiting assumptions what did
you learn from that in terms of things
that you discounted that you shouldn't
have things that were invisible that you
should have made visible
i'm wondering what you carry forward
from that
the two things are imagination dreaming
sitting back for a second and saying
and my partner mike moritz often hammers
this home for us in our partner meetings
when he was part of the team full-time
was
you know what if it goes right
because we can all you know we're in the
business of investing we're in the
business of not investing so assume for
a second goes right what could you
imagine this being
just imagine for a second instead of you
know you know it's the pre-parade
exercise in some sense just put on your
thinking caps i remember being in a
meeting with mike
and max lefton and jeremy stoppelman
when yelp was an idea
an idea
in
2005
and mike in a meeting said
i imagine a future where there are yelp
stickers outside restaurants
i mean that was an amazing insight an
amazing vision for the future which came
to be true
and so i'm always reminded about the
need for imagination in our business
then the need to be naive at some level
if you become a curmudgeon in the
venture business you're done
you need to be naive you need to dream
so that's the one the second one is
learning a little bit from behavioral
economics of the need to revisit your
assumptions
so i was really stuck in a some cost
fallacy where i'd made a decision to you
know my recommendation was for us to not
invest wrong decision so let's dig my
head into the ground and hide and just
keep saying we shouldn't invest we
shouldn't invest because why admit that
i was wrong
and so you need to be able to revisit
your decision and admit you were wrong
so we got the series they had square on
and we corrected it and we paid up for
the series b and i helped lead the
investment and i had to swallow my pride
i'm sorry team i should have recommended
it nine months ago my bad now we're
paying a high price for the investment
but i still believe in it and i think
that's huge upside and psychologically
that's a very difficult thing for people
to do and so we want to create that kind
of safety for us in our investment team
you